[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the top 10
most powerful magical beings of the
wizarding world
being is one of the three
classifications used by the british
ministry of magic to distinguish the
different magical creatures that inhabit
the wizarding world the others being
beast and spirit the term beings at
least for the most part refers to the
humanoid or at least seemingly humanoid
lives of the wizarding world and when i
say humanoid i mean possessing typical
human characteristics i.e one head a
standard number of appendages two eyes
etc although i suppose you could argue
that possession of these traits being
innately humanoid stems from a
relatively human-centric point of view
there are also a few exceptions to this
which you'll see down below
anyway with that distinction made i do
want to point out that there are still
quite a few humanoid creatures in the
wizarding world beyond just conventional
human witches and wizards which is why i
think that this will make for a fun list
this list will be ranked from least to
most powerful and i'll stick to canon to
support my rationale anyway let's dive
in 10. hags
hags which resemble warty evil looking
witches were vile child eating beings
that possessed rudimentary level magic
though commonly mixed up with witches
particularly in muggle literature it's
important to note that hags and witches
are two very different things
the appearance of a hag is what one
might imagine when trying to consider
the appearance of a witch but for those
who know of the magical world they know
that witches can actually be very
beautiful it's also worth mentioning
that the level of magic that hags
possess is significantly lower than that
of a normal witch in addition to being
strikingly ugly and possessing only four
toes on each foot the hag is doubly
scary because it just so happens to have
a taste for human flesh specifically the
flesh of children
despite their modest stature and limited
magic hags are still very dangerous
especially for children
9. trolls coming in at number 9 on the
list are trolls trolls which originally
come from norse mythology were giant
humanoid creatures of immense size
sometimes growing as tall as 12 feet and
weighing up to one tonne
it's also worth mentioning that there
are several different subspecies of
troll including forest trolls mountain
trolls river trolls and the troll of
nadroge a troll subspecies with
disproportionately large hands
trolls were incredibly dangerous
unpredictable violent and aggressive
creatures that had a taste for human
flesh making them particularly
terrifying it has been stated that
trolls possessed rudimentary level magic
however no one seems to really know how
this magical ability was utilized the
achilles heel of the troll however is
its intelligence as trolls are notably
quite stupid creatures in fact trolls
were so stupid that they had the lowest
wizarding exam failing grade named after
them eight vampire that's right vampires
which are so prevalent in other fantasy
worlds also exist in harry potter
rowling had this to say of vampires
although vampires exist in the world of
harry potter as shown by the literature
that harry and his friends study in
defense against the dark arts they play
no meaningful part in the story the
vampire myth is so rich and has been
exploited so many times in literature
and on film that i felt there was little
i could add to the tradition
the only vampire whom harry meets in the
books is sanguini in half blood prince
who makes a faintly comic appearance at
a party
however despite the vampire's absence
from the story it's worth noting that
they are powerful magical beings
vampires which mostly resembled a normal
witch or wizard in appearance are
perhaps best known for sucking out the
blood of their victims however vampires
have many other abilities as well
including but not limited to
heightened senses including vision
hearing sense of smell and the ability
to transfigure into a bat
the biggest weaknesses of a vampire are
a
that they don't use magic in the
traditional sense i.e magic of witches
wizards and b
garlic
7. pakwaji coming in at number seven we
have a creature native to america the
pakuwaji we first hear of the pakwaji
when isolt seya the founder of
ilvermorny encounters one in the
mountains pakwajis are short grey-faced
large-eared creatures distantly related
to the european goblin
fiercely independent tricky and not over
fond of humankind whether magical or
mundane it possesses its own powerful
magic
pakwajis hunt with deadly poisonous
arrows and enjoy playing tricks on
humans bakuachis are perhaps best known
for having one of the four ilvermorny
houses named in honour of them
6. giants coming in at number six are
giants giants are incredibly powerful
creatures that tend to live out their
lives in tribes completely separate from
the rest of the wizarding community
they are smarter than trolls but
stupider than humans and their innate
bloodthirsty nature has typically
resulted in their own population control
the secret to giant's power is in their
name they are giant in fact they are
larger than almost any other magical
creature equal in physical strength to
dragons and highly resistant to spells
giants have been known to side with
voldemort as we saw in both the first
and second wizarding wars however
despite their immense power they do have
an achilles heel their eyes
the eyes of giants are much more
vulnerable to spells and hacks and this
is how the good guys were able to take
them out this obvious vulnerability is
the only reason that they aren't higher
on the list
five centaurs coming in at number five
we have centaurs beings taken from greek
mythology that possess the upper body of
a human and the lower body of a horse
the biggest distinction between centaurs
of mythology and centaurs in harry
potter is that harry potter centaurs are
gifted in divination
a magical discipline that allows one to
gather insights into future events
centaurs are a bit of an odd one out on
this list because as it turns out
they're actually classified as beasts
however this was purely due to their own
request as they didn't want to share
being status with creatures like hags
and vampires
that said i still think they're more of
a being
centaurs boasted a large intimidating
physical appearance and were known to be
versed in many different magical
disciplines including healing magic
divination and astronomy they were also
naturally gifted at archery which made
them quite an imposing threat centaurs
could also perform non-verbal magic
though their magic was fairly limited
when compared with a human witch or
wizard four house elves house elves were
small beings often between two and three
feet tall with spintly appendages and
oversized heads and eyes they also had
pointy bat-like ears and high voices
which meant that they certainly weren't
particularly intimidating
however despite their unassuming
appearance and small stature house elves
are some of the most powerful magical
beings in the wizarding world
you see house elves could easily perform
wondless magic at a very high level
higher than a well-trained witch or
wizard they could operate with ease and
disarm a witch or wizard in a blink of
an eye
they were also fiercely protective of
those whom they had given their
allegiance but if that isn't enough to
convince you that they're powerful just
remember that harry potter himself once
remarked that house elves were better at
performing advanced magic than most
wizards the achilles heel of the house
elf their domestication
3. vela vila were magical beings that
resembled beautiful human females
sporting white gold hair and moon bright
skin
velars are known for using their good
looks to charm and hypnotize
however there are certainly more to
aveela than meets the eye as when angry
they are said to take on a less pleasant
appearance in moments of anger the face
of a feeler elongates into a sharp cruel
beaked burned head and scaly wings burst
from their shoulders in this state
velars can also launch balls of fire
from their hands
velas also possess their own form of
wandless magic it should also be
mentioned that veilers were sometimes
known to crossbreed with humans a
popular known quarter villa was fleur de
la cour
while breeding with humans granted them
certain human-like magical capabilities
it's also important to note that it's
unknown whether a half or quarter blood
velar could transform in the way that a
full villa could 2. goblins goblins
which are often compared to house elves
were fair-skinned beings a little bit
larger than elves that often possessed
dark slanted eyes pointed noses and
pointed ears
and like elves goblins could perform
wondless magic at a particularly high
level
perhaps an even higher level than elves
goblins were also skilled metalsmiths
and controlled the wizarding economy by
running the banking system and minting
all currency
however the biggest weapon that goblins
possessed were their brains as they were
particularly brilliant creatures that
were wrongfully regarded as subservient
and inferior in the eyes of many
ignorant witches and wizards
goblin kind of waged war on wizardkind
on numerous occasions throughout history
with the goal generally being the same
abolish the injustices ingrained within
wizarding culture however despite their
best efforts human witches and wizards
have always come out on top 1. humans
normal witches wizards coming in at
number one we have human witches and
wizards
now this may come as a bit of a surprise
to some of you because humans are
certainly less intimidating than many of
the other beings on this list humans
aren't 20 feet tall they aren't born
with impressive magical expertise they
can't fly and they aren't always very
intelligent however as a whole i think
it'd be hard to argue against wizard
kind being the most powerful
because after all they are the kingpins
of wizarding society and if we look at
the history books we can easily see that
the most powerful beings to have ever
graced the wizarding world have been
humans
with that said not all witches and
wizards are powerful and i would argue
that their innate level of power is
significantly lower than some of the
other beings on this list however their
ceiling of power if you will is the
highest as proven by famous wizards such
as dumbledore grindelwald voldemort and
even merlin and that's it for this video
what's your top 10 did i miss any
obvious beings as classified by the
ministry of magic comment down below
until next time
never mess with goblins harry
you